أنت تقول إن سياساتك الدفاعية والأمنية
تخلو من السياسة ، لكن
هذه صورة اعتاد عليها العالم
حتى الآن ، إنها دورة مستمرة
من قتل إراقة الدماء من
جميع الأطراف حقًا في
حالة عقاب جماعي يائس يائس
وفقط أعداد هائلة من القتلى
بانتظام في  إسرائيل في عام 2022.
إذن هذه هي الحقيقة
ولا يبدو أن هناك أي محاولة
للتفاوض على إنهاء الصراع الفعلي ،
أتساءل فقط
عما إذا كنت تنفق أي طاقة
ورأس مال سياسي مع هذا التحالف المتنوع
لمحاولة إنهاء  هذا الصراع
حسنًا أولاً وقبل كل شيء بالطريقة أه عرضت الحقائق
ليست دقيقة.
إسرائيل سلمية ومنذ حوالي شهر
للأسف ألقيت موجة جديدة من الرعب
على الجمهور الإسرائيلي
فقدنا 14 شخصًا في أربع
هجمات إرهابية مختلفة أه في بوشيبا حديرا نبرا
في مركز تل أبيب حيث أتى إرهابيون عرب مسلمون
بعضهم
محسوب على داعش بالبنادق وبدأوا في
إطلاق النار على الناس في الشارع  غير
مقبول ، لذلك أنا أعترض على
فكرة أه
أنت تعرف كلا الجانبين لا
عندما لا يهاجموننا ليس لدينا
مشاكل معهم ولكن عندما
يهاجموننا ، يجب أن أقاومهم
وضربهم في قواعدهم الإرهابية وهذا
ما الذي سيفعله أي زعيم وهذا
ما أفعله الآن فيما يتعلق بالصورة الأوسع ،
انظر
كما تعلم ، لن أقوم بإجراء
تجارب على أمن الإسرائيليين في
المرة الأخيرة في غزة ، لقد فعلنا ذلك
منذ حوالي 15 أو 16 عامًا.  من
غزة إلى الفلسطينيين ، تراجعنا
إلى الـ 67
صفًا التي انسحبناها وطردنا اليهود الذين يعيشون في غزة
وما حصلنا عليه بالمقابل هو
إطلاق عشرات الآلاف من الصواريخ علينا من الجحيم ،
فأنا لست في مجال أه تجارب اللعب.
على الشعب الإسرائيلي ، ما سأفعله
وأنا أفعله
هو تحقيق السلام بين الناس من الأسفل إلى الأعلى
الحصول على المزيد من الوظائف للفلسطينيين
وظائف ذات رواتب أفضل لتحسين الاقتصاد
وهذا ما أؤمن به ويجب أن
أقول إن الفلسطينيين يشهدون
ازدهارًا غير مسبوق